[Musique]
le fait d aider c'est très fort à
l'intérieur de toi donc à qu'arrive à la
maison puis qui est une personne de
personne qui est décédée durant la nuit
ou durant la journée que t'as pas pu les
sauver peut plus rien faire on dit que
ça ça reste toujours dans ta tête tu es
toujours c'est comme si la tête est
toujours au travail
c'est un extrait de témoignages très
parlant de kim klavel qui étaient avec
nous ce matin
cette jeune boxeuse aussi infirmière qui
a prêté main forte dans le siège s'est
dès lors de la première vague mais on
reçoit justement ce matin la psychologue
docteur pascale brillon qui a écrit un
livre pour aider les soignants pour
aider les uns dans dr brion bonjour
bonjour bon matin à vous aussi on les
appelait les anges gardiens au début de
la pandémie ces travailleurs de la santé
et firmi infirmières premiers répondants
les thérapeutes
mais là on sent qu'il y en a beaucoup
d'anges gardiens qui sont fatigués après
des mois de polémique oui tout à fait ça
a été un long marathon ils ont été
considérés services essentiels on peut
penser à tous les professionnels de la
santé physique mais tous les
professionnels de la santé mentale aussi
qui ont été à pied d'oeuvre pour aider
la population pendant tous ces longs
mois
et puis quel est le marathon il s'étire
le fil d'arrivée semble reculer un peu
donc c'est sûr que ça contribue à
l'épuisement de professionnels de ces
gens et vous avez conçu un guide qui
s'appelle entretenir ma vitalité des
dents à dans lequel vous donner des
conseils pour pas pour tenter de garder
l'équilibré à travers tout ça ce que
vous pouvez nous dire un peu là quel
serait votre meilleur conseil ce matin
mais en fait c'est un guide qui cherche
à prévenir la fatigue de compassion ou
le trauma vicario chez les gens qui sont
en posture dédain donc on a dû tout les
professionnels la santé physique et
mentale mais aussi tous les projets dans
tous les aidants naturels les
travailleurs humanitaires
les gens qui doivent constamment être en
contact avec la détresse d'autrui
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour non
seulement avoir des stratégies dans le
quotidien
pour maintenir cette vitalité pour
continuer à être dans la bonne posture
dira politique d'empathie pour continuer
à faire ce métier là longtemps et avec
plaisir mais aussi des stratégies pour
pouvoir mieux rebondir quand
un événement qui bouleverse arrive aussi
que dans une journée de travail dans un
contact avec un moment où il pas peur un
papa qui sont malades depuis longtemps
il peut y avoir des moments où les dents
est en contact avec des situations
bouleversante
bon ben j'ai vu quelqu'un qui a agressé
une collègue j'ai reçu moins de
l'hostilité où j'ai eu quelqu'un dans
mon entourage qui s'est suicidé j'ai une
plainte de mon ordre professionnel alors
il ya toutes sortes d'événements qui
peut favoriser un épuisement plus grands
et là aussi on sonne des stratégies pour
pouvoir mieux rebondir dans ces moments
tout à fait particulier charnière
souvent dans un cheminement
d'accompagnement qui peut aussi ébranlé
l'aide
oui c'est pas facile avec la pandémie
parce que ce nombre d'événements
s'accumulent puis on voit pas la fin
donc c'est pourtant ça va se terminer
absolument il peut avoir beaucoup
d'événements qu'on appelle des blessures
morales par exemple dans ce livre où on
peut réaliser que j'ai assisté quelque
chose qui ne correspond pas à mes
valeurs je me suis engagé pour un
versement d'or et pourtant j'ai
l'impression de contribuer à quelque
chose qui ne me correspond plus et ça
c'est très très douloureux de dire je
fais partie d'un système
j'encourage ce système alors que il va à
l'encontre de ce que change je considère
bon et juste
est ce aussi peut avoir eu beaucoup de
moments comme ça pendant la pandémie où
on a fait de notre mieux où on a
contribué à un système qui ont séduit
c'est pour tout à fait la bonne chose
j'aurais pas fait les choses de cette
façon
ou bien c'est pas comme ça que j'aurais
voulu accompagner cette personne qui
était en fin de vie et pourtant entouré
de gens qui est habillé comme des
astronautes sans pouvoir avoir l'aide de
leur père de la famille dont il peut y
avoir eu effectivement beaucoup
d'événements qu'on appelle des blessures
morales et pu contribuer à l'épuisement
des hindous et vous avez également
parler de fatigue de compassion donc il
ya des saignant j'imagine qu'on peut
reconnaître à travers sa plus important
c'est de pouvoir prendre soin de soi
tout à fait la fatigue de compassion se
manifeste souvent par une impression de
ne plus être capable de s'immerger dans
le monde de l'ordre depuis le cap 1
de réagir aussi quand nos proches nous
donne des bonnes ou des mauvaises
nouvelles des gens y vont de leur père
ce cas je reviens du travail
j'ai vu tellement de choses
bouleversante que quand je rentre à la
maison
j'ai l'impression d'être déshumanisé
j'ai l'impression de ne plus avoir cette
capacité d'empathie de ne plus avoir ce
plaisir à aider que j'avais autrefois je
me sens froid je me sens comme un glaçon
ça ne me ressemble pas et pourtant c'est
comme ça que je me sens maintenant comme
si j'étais profondément usées et
vieillies prématurément et donc ce sont
vraiment des signes de fatigue de
compassion alors que le trauma vicariat
bien c'est vraiment plus un syndrome on
a l'impression qu'on commence à avoir
peur comme notre clientèle on a été
marquée par des événements qui nous ont
raconté on a été marqué par ce qu'on a
vu au travail et on commence avons nous
mêmes des flashbacks qui nous dérange
parce que ya eu un événement qu'on n'est
pas capable de digérer juste entretenir
ma vitalité d'un docteur pascale brillon
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ça
m'a fait plaisir voire jours l'envoi
bonne journée